a silent walk in Dunkirk charity workers
led a commemoration in the northern
French town for at least 27 people who
died trying to cross the English Channel
one year ago most were Kurds from Iraq
including children
so I thought it was really important to
come here and to um to remember what has
happened and what is happening
still
why the tragedy happen though is still
not clear British and French officials
traded blame over why the boat wasn't
rescued but some details have begun to
emerge a French newspaper investigation
has revealed the victims repeatedly
called French Rescue Services with their
location but they were sent no
assistance and even at times seemed to
be mocked
a transcript of some of the calls paints
a chilling picture
help please I'm in the water says an
asylum seeker yes but you're in English
Waters replies a French rescue operator
no no not English Waters in French
Waters please come fast
then the phone line cuts and the
operator is heard saying oh well if you
can't hear me you won't be saved
despite the danger people keep trying
waiting for a chance in Desperate
conditions on the French Coast Karen
left Afghanistan two years ago he
doesn't want to apply for asylum in
France because he thinks life will be
better in Britain
we have to go of course no one wants to
die but we have to go because we have no
choice
the British and French governments
recently agreed to boost security and
cooperation in France to try and stop
the crossings but Charities say unless
there are more legal ways to reach the
UK women men and children will continue
to risk their lives Natasha Butler Al
Jazeera Dunkirk